ich habe zwei freunde von mir allein
anhand des auftretens und ein paar
fragen an personen erwarten lassen
welcher job zu welcher person gehört was
dabei herausgekommen ist erfahrt ihr in
dieser folge von test was denkst du wie
viele der job so richtig zuordnen kannst
glaubst kann richtig gleiche aber auch
richtig schwer sein
ich nehme mal optimistisch 54 ich glaube
5 ist schon gar nicht so einfach aber
ich werde einfach gute fragen stellen
ein passant richters hin
wir haben als erstes friseur bzw
friseurinnen jetpilot piloten lehrerin
oder lehrer model moderator der
moderatorin regisseur und student
studentin und der so coole berufe ich
meine über auch immer studiert kraft
okay wenn ich jetzt die leute gerade
laufen sehen manche sachen hätte ich
echt nicht gerechnet aber ich würde
sagen wir fangen wir an mit nummer 1
alles klar
ok also irgendwie sein auftreten sagt
mir dass etwas kreatives ist also im
prinzip friseur aufklärt was machst du
beruflich schon mal kampfjets geflogen
eigentlich nach dafür bislang aber davon
war ich irgendwie ausgehen lehrer ein
bisschen jungen vielleicht model könnte
schon sein regisseur würde irgendwie
auch gut ins bild passen ist der student
könnten halt irgendwie die meisten seien
ich lege mich fest du bist mein
regisseur nummer zwei hast du ein hund
[Musik]
selbständig sein feld leer war schon mal
weg temperatur unsere waffe kommen seien
komplett würde ich auch jetzt mal sagen
kann man nicht mal eben so selbstständig
machen so soll ich sagen neue moderator
ist
du bist irgendwie du bist mein müssen
ein student max filme gucken vier filme
an einem filmset gearbeitet
das feld kommt nichts weg dann bist du
regisseur sag mal was schlaues scheiße
sein okay okay das war die ganze zeit
meine vermutung irgendwie oder magst du
menschen
irgendwie deinen auftritten sagt
kampfjet pilot wie kein anderes ich
möchte jetzt nicht zu nahetreten fest
ich gerade jemand weiß ist sehr cool
campino zu sagen ich möchte dass
niemandem absprechen konnte wurde sein
das ist schon mal ein flugzeug geflogen
ja das ist wahr das ist mal unzulässige
frage du bist mein copilot für läufer
und sagt okay halt bis zu 24 das ist
eine stimme du hast deine stimme magst
du haare
grundsätzlich hat die hand sehen und
fragen über ich würde jetzt sagen lehrer
oder friseur du bist irgendwie fühle
mich so wird von auftreten und der
stimme her bist du mein moderator von
anfang an stand dann ja okay du bist
moderator ist ein freund hast du dein
studium schon verlassen studiert du bist
du schon fertig mit dem studium bei
mädels noch übrig ist meine lehrerin
haben hallo hallo model oder friseurin
das bist du selbst zuerst rechnet sich
nicht frank des öfter vor der kamera
also sicher sein regelmäßig versuche aus
dem bauch heraus bis du meine frisörin
und du dann folgt ich meine morde gehen
1000 arbeitsplätze
das geht schon ja gesagt dass kaiser als
model stimme ist das mal alles klar wann
werdet dann wird es aufgelöst ist jetzt
unbedingt wissen jetzt sofort ok chats
mal wie viele jobs so richtig zugeordnet
hast 75 bitte die hände wenn euch der
richtige job zugeordnet wurde perfekt
hat funktioniert war weiter ja das war
für mich irgendwie so das war so eine
kategorie ist hätte ich irgendwie auch
vertauschen können voll gut finde
zufrieden
dankeschön ich habe die richtige
prognose gab es alle erwarten dass du
schön dass ihr wieder zugeschaut haben
falls sie auch mal mitmachen wollt bei
einer solch lustigen folge dann klickt
im link unten in der beschreibung
bewertet das video wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder hallo ich habe schon
mal ein flugzeug geflogen